ils ont dévoilé les conseils pour avoir
un esprit sain dans un corps sain vous
c'est déjà mort quoi
considérez
n'y arriverez plus on va commencer tout
ça avec le premier conseil à savoir ne
jamais faire ses courses le ventre vide
ça c'est un conseil que nous donne
souvent c'est on a entendu celui-là
jamais faire ses courses vendredi ça
veut dire qu'avant de faire les courses
tu fais des voilà tu habites à libérer
tu fais des gestes tu fais un kiff tu
vois et tu vas me prendre vers les
courses tu vois moi je sais quand je
vais faire les courses à chaque fois
à quel endroit
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire les
yeux dans les yeux enfin face caméra ou
téléspectateurs quel a été la dernière
fois vous avez surtout l'année tout seul
surtout l'année tout seul avec un caddie
mec j'adore vous êtes mal tombé j'adore
ça j'adore les cadres
je vais très souvent supermarché et la
dernière fois quand j'ai vu franchement
les biscuits là les petits loups à 4,90
ça m'a choqué
vous remplissez votre caddie vous faites
une livraison mais pas du tout il sait
même pas comment il payait pas de
commande
la livraison n'existait même pas à
l'époque qu'est-ce que vous achetez en
priorité moi des artichauts
les cuisiner comment les artistes
à la Camerounaise
cuisine
de petit déjeuner l'idée c'est de voir
qu'est-ce que tu achètes quand tu as
faim j'achèterai tout en fait
impossible de résister à la tentation en
moins de 30 secondes Lola craque pour
trois paquets de gâteaux et un sachet de
bonbons il va se beaucoup de choses dans
son cerveau on sait que ces régions sont
particulièrement impliquées dans ce
qu'on appelle le système de la
récompense ce qui fait que on va
associer à quelque chose de qu'on
perçoit du plaisir et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ces zones là sont
également impliquées dans la prise de
décision
en résumé quand lola a faim et qu'elle
voit de la nourriture grave et sucrée
son cerveau lui dit ça a l'air génial
j'en ai envie achète le moi
il y a un autre conseil ne pas se peser
n'importe quand on sait que beaucoup se
passe quand ils ont le temps quand ils y
pensent mais en réalité évidemment bien
précis dans la journée pour vérifier son
poids par exemple moi je me pèse 4 fois
par jour
il y a un moment très particulier où il
faut se poser vous savez quel est le
moment
entre 4 et 4h30 du matin tu mets ton
réveil tu vas te poser tu vas te
recoucher tu fais chier tout le monde
n'importe quoi
lorsque Marie monte sur la balance avec
la vessie pleine elle pèse 100,9 kg mais
après un petit tour aux toilettes
entre 200 et 300 g de moins franchement
je suis hyper surprise et oui un pipi
c'est en moyenne 250 g de plus sur la
balance pour la grosse commission
comptez 200 g en fait à chaque fois que
vous mangez buvez quelque chose ou aller
aux toilettes votre poisson change faut
se poser le matin à jeun déshabillé
après être allé uriné pour avoir un
poids de
référencement des conseils pardon
derrière donc les gars donc vous avez
entendu donc parce qu'en fait on va
j'aimerais revoir le graphique parce que
la journée du gars c'est immense il va
chier
le gars empêche faire ta tournée aux
toilettes ça a l'air immense dès qu'il
va prendre un café il va chier un truc
de fou quoi le gars il est arrivé
quand même incroyable c'est quoi ce
graphique non mais sans déconner
il y a du papier
je connais non mais voilà et donc le mec
mange la même chose voir le matin il
mange voilà des conneries qui a déjà vu
une assiette comme ça en Asie et ça
c'est l'assiette que tu manges jamais
c'est l'assiette MiTo quand tu vas dans
les buffets au Club Med tout ça c'est
toujours une assiette avec des crudités
et après tu la prends tu la mets de côté
tu vas chercher des trucs dégueulasse la
connais cette assiette je l'ai mangé
avec le concombre voilà arrêtez vous
pouvez avoir jusqu'à 3 kg d'écart quand
vous posez le matin et le soir
[Applaudissements]
il habitait à la maison je peux te dire
je croyais qu'il y avait l'ouverture de
la chasse frère
[Applaudissements]
il y avait des animaux morts je sais pas
ce qu'ils faisaient non mais c'est un
truc de fou non mais lui chie les
écureuils et pourquoi hahaha
quoi je t'explique les gens les gens les
gens étaient choqués les gens étaient
choqués mais je suis venu chez moi c'est
vrai j'ai tué vos chiottes
je t'explique je suis passé devant frère
je croyais frère j'ai demandé j'ai cru
qu'il y avait un problème jusque non
mais sans rien une remonter des eaux
des boules de pétanque
attends je t'explique un truc de fouille
je suis pas des boules de flipper tu as
encore une charmille allez le prochain
concerne l'hygiène Nanterre tiens c'est
pour toi ça
je sais pas combien de fois vous changez
votre brosse à dents mais en tout cas si
les poils de votre brosse à dents
ressemblent à une coupe à votre coupe de
cheveux en sortant du lit il est
peut-être temps d'en changer sachez que
tes brosse à dents ça se il faut il faut
les changer très rare voilà ce que vous
changez votre brosse à dents très
rarement
j'attends que les poils soient tous
souples et j'adore donc ah bah oui mais
c'est pour ça que c'est bien des
conséquences
[Rires]
se
à dents avait des poils comme ça
on va simuler un brossage avec une
brosse à dents neuve et une brosse à
dents usagée pour essayer de déterminer
s'il y a des différences alors sur la
brosse à dents usager on voit une trace
qui est plus large mais on voit aussi
qu'il y a une zone qui a pas été
atteinte par le brossage c'est la même
peinture simplement les poils sont
moins uniformes et il y a certaines
zones où il va falloir appuyer plus fort
et plus longtemps pour bien nettoyer
là c'est là où toutes les caries
pourraient venir se loger en fait
exactement les caries et les dents
jaunes
dentaire
c'est formidable ça c'est comme un
karcher pour les dents ça enlève tout
nickel et après vous vous brossez les
dents
par contre dans 2 ans quoi
vraiment
je te mets dans l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est génial
comme la mienne
mais c'est vachement bien vraiment je
m'en fous vachement me commander tu peux
aller là ma pharmacie
tous les jours je vais pas le fabriquer
quel barbe ça me fera plaisir mais si je
vais pas le fabriquer vous êtes gentil
tu m'amènes ça demain et vous allez me
remercier c'est formidable vraiment
merci prochain conseil qui a eu dans 6
moi j'adore ces conseils moi je peux
rester des ordres
calme-toi calme-toi faites attention
fais attention à son cou à sa
consommation d'eau ah bah oui boire
beaucoup c'est bien mais boire trop
c'est pas bon et pour savoir si vous
êtes en bonne santé vérifier la couleur
de votre urine alors moi non mais c'est
ce qu'il faut faire quand vous faites
pipi en fait vous faites pipi moi je
fais pipi comme ça que je suis à table
je prends le vert moi je suis puni comme
ça pour moi
parce que je vous dis à un moment la
couleur de l'urine c'est votre capital
santé si vous avez une urine par exemple
qui est trop vous savez trop mousseuse
si vous aviez c'est que vous faites à
mon avis vous avez c'est pas bon je vous
dis l'urine trop mousseux c'est pas bon
il est trop foncé c'est que vous avez
besoin d'oligo-éléments
l'urine trop foncée
si l'urine est très très clair c'est que
c'est très bon ah ouais je connais mon
père et médecin
il a péché Johnson il a libéré
[Rires]
jaune foncé sur les urines de quelqu'un
qui boit pas assez celle-ci c'est
beaucoup trop dilué ça veut dire que
cette personne boit trop et l'idéal
c'est cette couleur là c'est quelqu'un
qui boit suffisamment si on boit pas
assez il y a pas assez de liquide pour
éliminer les déchets donc les déchets
vont s'accumuler donc à terme au risque
d'en mourir parce que le corps
s'empoisonne mais si on boit pas assez
de façon chronique mais un peu quand
même à ce moment-là les urines sont trop
concentrés et les déchets vont
cristalliser les uns avec les autres et
on va former des calculs urinaires et
puis l'autre risque de ne pas boire
assez complètement différent c'est un
risque d'affection urinaire les germes
peuvent remonter dans la vessie de façon
naturelle et si on boit pas assez ils
vont se multiplier dans la vessie donc
il faut boire un minimum autour de 1,5
par jour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce qu'ils veulent pas aller aux
toilettes à l'école
ça fait alors moi je vous dis moi la
dernière fois la dernière fois je
t'envoieure je suis sur véridique ok je
suis sur l'autoroute je suis à 130 j'ai
envie de pisser je suis levé comme ça
j'ai pissé par la fenêtre
[Rires]
je me suis fait flasher les gars par
contre
deux minutes dans cette machine c'est
très long quand on a la vessie prête à
exploser on va pouvoir analyser les
images maintenant
cette tâche qui est là c'est moi qui
sont en train de me dire oh là là j'ai
ma vesti qui est gonflé il faut que j'y
aille c'est ça il y a une deuxième zone
c'est la singula elle va permettre de
prendre des décisions et là en
l'occurrence de se dire est-ce que je
vais faire pipi ou non d'accord voilà le
troisième région on appelle ça le
cortextrait frontal médial qui va donner
l'ordre à votre vessie de ne pas faire
pipi qu'on a très envie de faire pipi
bah ça prend toute notre attention et on
n'est pas capable de penser à autre
chose
on peut pas se concentrer sur autre
chose donc forcément tu sais voilà c'est
c'est fou c'est moi la dernière fois
j'ai eu des problèmes
insoluble qu'est-ce qu'il veut moi quand
j'étais petit il y a quelques années on
avait qu'une chiotte à la maison et donc
comme elle était nombreux 5 enfants et
les parents et la grand-mère donc on
était tous gênés
moi j'attendais que personne dans
l'appartement pour y aller donc
évidemment je me suis retenu une fois
pendant 15 jours 15 jours 15 jours alors
je vous dis pas les 15 jours je vous dis
pas les donneurs non c'est vrai dans le
jour et donc je vais jouer au foot avec
les copains je tire un coup de sur le
ballon et évidemment tout est sorti
c'était la honte de ma vie et ça te fait
rire toi
[Rires]
chez lui dans sa chambre
ah bon pour pipi ah ouais ça me fait
chier non mais j'ai pas recommencer
l'histoire c'est très pratique
c'est trop loin
faire pipi
non c'est vrai le pot c'est vrai c'est
très pratique à 5h du mat quand même moi
je me réveille tous les jours vers 5h
d'ailleurs genre les infos tout de suite
ah mais en fait tu quand tu es en fait
quand tu es un peu saoulé tout le monde
c'est génial moi j'en ai rien j'en ai
rien à carrer moi je peux te réveiller à
n'importe quelle heure je monte car mon
cube
commence à faire tous les trucs qu'il a
dans sa chambre ah ben non il y a que ça
là mais c'est vrai que chez moi on
n'aime pas d'ailleurs j'aime pas quand
on parle de popo pipi tout ça
il y a pas Jean-Marie Bigard ce soir
d'aller aux toilettes c'est un nom
scientifique qui s'appelle la shit
attaque et on est souvent victime du
shit attends mais c'est pas une blague
[Applaudissements]